thousand Corpses was the first blue team
did so that was kind of just a crazy
of whatever you seen this
girl yeah they won't play Nancy Drew
with this local legend people call dr.
Satan stupid kids probably got
themselves lost first anything is a
learning experience and then you know at
the time it never became what I wanted
Devil's Rejects by that point I learned
a lot of first them so that movie was
more where I wanted to be and eat with
each movie you just can't help but just
learn more and more how to achieve what
double goal is you have something in
your mind trying to get it on film and I
think Lords of Salem probably is a more
sophisticated in the way shot in the
other is the other movies I would shoot
handheld and more rough because I really
like how those type of movies look but
this one's a more composed controlled
sort of cinematic film sometimes I mean
I really like movies that are very
natural and I was watching I mean this
may not seem like a very natural type
blue but I was watching Close Encounters
the other night and just the scenes in
the family would grow a year in his
family and teri garr and the kids in the
background screaming and just a
naturalness of that setting is what I
love and we do so it doesn't feel like
this sort of scripted put together thing
it feels like just reeled it those
that's what I always want to try to
achieve that's what I love in movies I
want the stuff from my breakfast table
can cause tennis now everything's so
polished I don't think everything should
be something the goal to make everything
so perfect I find boring
okay okay I'm wrong I'm wrong I'm wrong
Roy all right tell me you are close to
death their movies was always my passion
growing up as a kid but and music but I
mean maybe it's easier now because of
the way camera equipment is but you know
growing up it's like to make a movie
whose much more difficult and say hey
let's start a band so so you know one
suppressant over the other but as the
the van and music were not in time
speciality came time to make music
videos and stuff I always direct those
the music videos became good training
ground for features to a point amenia is
a very it's a very different set of
skills but there's some aspect to it and
that really led to films
on a crime
I mean with every project that I've ever
done every movie over everything you
know you never feel like you get right
so you're always in the quest to do it
better the next time we do you know I
guess have you felt that you've got it
right you quit so you're always on your
question to take it to the next level
that's really the way I always look at
you